más restricciones de viaje las naciones
del sur de áfrica se enfrentan al temor
mundial por la propagación de la
variante omicron reino unido estados
unidos y los países de la unión europea
están entre los primeros en cerrar sus
fronteras una decisión que fomentó
acusaciones de injusticia y afro fobia
pero incluso algunas naciones africanas
incluyendo a angola ruanda marruecos y
egipto siguieron el ejemplo de occidente
tenemos que resistir a las restricciones
de viaje injustificadas y sin pruebas
científicas que sólo sirven para
perjudicar aún más a los países en
desarrollo
además de sudáfrica las prohibiciones de
viajes internacionales apuntan a 9
países incluyendo a botsuana mozambique
namibia y zimbabue la organización
mundial de la salud instó al mundo a
seguir la ciencia en lugar de imponer
prohibiciones de viajes marsans la
aparición de la variante omicron
altamente mutadas subraya cuán peligrosa
y precaria es nuestra situación
deberían agradecer a sudáfrica
por detectar la variante y reportarla en
lugar de sancionarlos
la nueva variante del coronavirus ha
provocado un aumento en los contagios
por kobe 19 en sudáfrica con más de 2800
casos reportados el domingo por encima
de un promedio diario de 500 casos en la
semana anterior y 275 en la anterior a
ella queda por ver qué tan transmisible
resulta ser la variante omicron y qué
tan graves son los síntomas de las
nuevas infecciones